hello nice to meet you see you oh here
we go
I didn't know that was you sit done hey
guys
I saw your badge back at the greenroom
oh really
yeah okay on the couch take it we could
swap I sold it on reddit huh I'm sure
you got like 50 cents anyway you just
announced definitely outsider I think it
yeah a lot of people were kind of
predicting this seems like the time for
dishonor to DLC right like a prey just
came out Oh what are you talking about
was a total surprise
come on so tell us about it was like to
have this out in the open now yeah so um
it is called death of the outsider it
stars Billy lurk that's the thing we're
really excited about we've been waiting
years to do this she's a fan favorite
she first appeared in knife of dunwall
and the brigmore witches she's going
after her old mentor Dowd and together
they conceived this like almost
impossible assassination mission to take
down the outsider god-like figure in our
world something I should say though is
we push really hard to make this
standalone right so even if you have not
played dishonored before you can go
check out death of the outsider it's a
little shorter than a full release it's
just a few missions but it does feature
ability lurk and she has our own powers
our own gadgets and you don't need any
prior dishonored stuff you can buy it as
a standalone thing okay yeah the the
opening trailer if I'm not mistaken was
just Megan Foster and doubt that we're
seeing yeah this is Billy lurk so um
it's a spoiler cover your ears if you
haven't played Dishonored 2 but there's
a character named Billy lurk from the
earlier Dishonored games who is in
Dishonored 2 under an assumed name right
as the boat captain Megan foster captain
of a boat that she owns called the
dreadful whale which is an anagram for
farewell doubt so she still got some
unresolved issues with her old mentor
and after the adventure with Emily in
Dishonored 2 in karnataka they go their
separate ways and she begins to hunt for
doubt yeah you're saying um it's been of
like fans about asking to know more
about what we previously called Megan
Foster and everything because she's such
a cool character and dishonor to and
what you said knife of dunwall and
thing was this were you always trying to
explore the story was it largely because
of fans wanted to know so much more
about her you know um there was a moment
in early on and Dishonored two's
development where the idea popped up
about revisiting or visiting this
concept you know sort of the end of the
outsider and it just percolated in the
back of my head and I would talk to
various team members about it and all of
us love doubt as a character where would
he be 15 years later at the end of his
life an older man with regrets Billy now
that she's found her footing at the end
of dishonour to and she she's got new
purpose what would she do you know she's
now the actor in the in the world she's
the one that's gonna like realize this
this almost impossible assassination
mission so you know at one level
dishonored is about badass supernatural
assassin moving through a steampunk City
killing off high-value targets
aristocrats and corrupt leaders and
things like that another level it's a
family story so the whole Dishonored
series which we've worked on for eight
years now has had Corvo attano as a
protagonist it's had doubt as a
protagonists it's had emily kaldwin and
Corvo as a protagonist to Dishonored 2
and now billy lurk is uh closing out
that arc for this part of the dishonored
fiction yeah I do want to talk about how
its standalone because I think like two
days ago after Welsh Bethesda it's like
oh you think you can get it for $30 even
if you didn't play dishonored - yeah I
was just telling someone like talking to
dingo becau barley designer we we
realized at some point if we did this
that it may be for some percentage of
the audience their first and only foray
into Dishonored sure they might be the
first time they played the game which is
a weird concept you know so it had to
work as a as a standalone piece about
this woman who's was part of the
underworld and now has some remorse
about that wants to set things right
going after this legendary assassin
who's gone into retirement finding him
and then undertaking this mission so it
stands alone you know both in terms of
you can just buy it and play it but also
fictionally you understand the world if
you if you move into it when you get
into sort of that format when you're
offering something that's that's just
like this when normally it would just be
DLC does that does that alter maybe how
you think about this the scope of what
you're giving people in anyway yeah I
mean all of those things are uh you know
like I don't know how interesting this
is to most people who play games but
like there's what you can do in the
given amount of time there's like how
much it should cost there's how much of
it should be reuse of space in Karnataka
versus new levels versus some old levels
but that have been heavily updated new
locations do you scrap all the existing
powers and movement model and start over
because it's a new protagonist like
Billy lerk has entirely different powers
than Corvo or Emily had or Dowd and you
can play through with her powers and
once you've completed the game then you
can play what we call og+ original game
plus where you can play it again with
some of Corvo and Emily's powers instead
swapped out okay but she has her own
gadgets too she doesn't use the pistol
crossbow combination that they used
she has like a voltaic gun that fires
like magnetically charged particles okay
so she's a really interesting character
but it's like where you put the work
because there's a lot of work that goes
into something like this and where you
put that you know to give value to the
people that love the series and want to
see Billy lurk want to explore Karnataka
again want to take this thing with the
outsider too it's in conclusion those
are all like highly subjective calls
that we have to make during the course
of development um so in addition to
being standalone do you think it's
something that can be an entry point for
people who haven't played this honored
yeah absolutely yeah that's a you know
again like we heard to us as we were
talking about it wow it is possible it's
going to be a small percentage of the on
it audience I guess because most people
who are familiar with Dishonored one or
two or the NACA dunwall brigmore witches
but when we made knife of dunwall and
brigmore witches it was very popular DLC
for Dishonored one but only people who
already had this on or one could play it
you know so so I don't know I mean I
definitely think it works and it's
exciting for some players that might
have a different reason for for playing
this they weren't interested in the
former one but they like Billy lerk as a
character more or they like the idea of
going after the outside or more I don't
know but it's definitely playable if you
have never played dishonor before it's
it's a potential entry point to the
series do you ever have a concern when
you're using like fan favorite
characters or existing locations that
somebody who maybe starts out on this
and goes back to the first is honored
going back in time doesn't work as well
as as kind of starting here no I didn't
think about that that's an interesting
idea like I mean every there's so many
players out there and we mostly hear
from the people that like Dishonored 1
and 2 or our DLC for Dishonored one
wanted to knife of dunwall brigmore
witches but it is entirely possible that
someone out there is going to play all
of these in reverse order or something
so and I have no idea what that
experience would be like but it'd be
interesting I think like in a way this
this whole thing constantly
cross-references the political
assassination of the Empress yeah in the
first game and it that's still
reverberating you know like doubt fuels
he made the world a worse place he
destabilized the world by doing that
Corvo misses the woman he loved Emily it
was her mother
Billy lurk was dad's right hand during
that time and was there that day
participated in it and doesn't want to
just feel guilty about it she wants to
do something about it so if she sees the
outsider as a concentration of power
that can be abused by people and so by
taking him out she'd removed that from
the world
yeah so it's it's all in you know the
whole thing like weaves back and forth
across the time line of roughly 15 years
I'm curious it seems like with Billy
you're going for a more gadget oriented
approach or did she have like outsider
powers as well despite the fact that
she's trying to kill him she's not
marked by the outsider her powers come
from another source okay um so again
that asks supernatural assassin that's
the that's the promise that if you play
the game that's what you get but she
doesn't use blink she uses something
called this place where she can imagine
being two places at once
and choose which one she wants to go to
basically uncle which means she can
leave a marker behind that no one else
can see and later go to it which
effectively means she can go through
walls she doesn't have to have line of
sight to the place she's going she also
has a power called void strike that she
can charge up
she has siblings where she can take
someone down and take their identity so
their allies speak to her as if she were
you know the person that she's copying
basically and then she has a talisman
she's carried presumably that we say
[ __ ] she was a teenage girl given to her
by her friend Deirdre that allows her to
hear the thoughts of rats so she can if
you get near pools of rats which in
Dishonored one we're very scary yeah
with Billy's talisman she can get near
them it's called rat whispers and she
she gets little clues and pieces of
information from that rats so yeah she
has supernatural powers but they come
from artifacts he has the sword that was
originally used to sacrifice the
outsider she had are made up of void
particles she has an eye called the
sliver of the eye that is a big chunk of
the eye of the divinity that existed
before the outsider to get super nerdy
on you and then she has this talisman
rat whispers so yeah she's a combination
on top of that she has the hook mine's
the magnetic thing that will you can put
on the wall and will drag people across
the room you can put multiple in
different spots and it will pull them
apart hook mines are super fun to play
with when I saw her I instantly thought
of kano from Mortal Kombat and I can't
unsee it very own brand just a little
anecdote I'm sorry someone said earlier
you know I worked on the original Deus
Ex and the second Deus Ex and we had a
character that was pretty popular called
Ana Navarre who had a cybernetic eye
that glowed red I think and so someone
said oh this reminds me of Anna Navarro
as well so I I think once in a while the
world needs a character with an evil red
glowing eye all right I'm gonna come
back to ya but the fact that is death of
the outsider it's called it seems pretty
bold because you think if you Kelley
outsider how do you do like it
Dishonored 3 yeah I guess you have to
get creative
yeah or have an alternate power source
outside okay yeah uh I do want to talk
about like um I kind of was asking
you actually brought up Deus Ex you
worked on Deus Ex and you I know you did
a QA on System Shock yeah back it when
it was origin and yeah but I'm curious
you know you see arcane is known as kind
of the torch pair of immersive Sims
which you know it's like the dry term
for these like emergent gameplay based
you know like just putting you in these
realized worlds where you can kind of
use the tools that you're supposed to
play with it and find different like
experiment differently with different
mechanics and systems I'm curious why
I've talked to you extensively about in
the past why this kind of game seems to
be making a comeback because like breath
of the wild is doing this emergent
gameplay kind of stuff Metal Gear Solid
5 even did more of that open-ended kind
of stuff whereas before it was like a
you know more linear fine-tuned stealth
game what do you think it is it's
bringing back these kind of games you
know I think there's strength in all
kinds of games recently I played what
remains of Edith Finch it's one of my
favorite games everyone should go play
that game it's amazing every now and I
pulled my phone out and I play hoplite
which is an amazing little roguelike hit
mango was one of my favorite games the
year that it came out you know but I
also loved horizon zero dawn
I love destiny you know there are many
different game types and reasons to play
them but I think more and more people
who grew up with games like all of us
and who have played a lot of games they
don't want to just follow a trail of
breadcrumbs they want to make decisions
they want to see surprising outcomes by
mixing and matching things so on the
indie scene you have things like
terraria you know and but even in the
the very high-end commercial market big
games with lots of heavy art and you
know that take a long time to make and
our big in scope you have people
experimenting in the Dishonored games or
the prey games you know breath of the
wild is a good example you know the
video everybody shared where he grabs
the goose and goes after the Giants and
then the giant hits the goose and all
the other geese show up an attack or
whatever I mean it was fantastic I
played pray as they were hitting alpha
that that's a team that I didn't work
with it was in Austin but it came back
to Austin and I played two playthroughs
back to back about 70 hours of pray
around alpha gave him lots of notes and
the first playthrough I
did all human skills like engineer and
things like that I did no sigh powers ii
when i did only sigh powers just to
really see the difference and it took me
about 70 hours to do those two
playthroughs and i swear I told raphaël
colantonio my dear friend the creative
director and Ricardo Bear and Susan cath
our producer like our banister cath
Manus for now I was talking to them and
I told them the like one of my favorite
moments in a game ever in the history of
my playing games 23 years in the
industry in my top 100 moments was a
moment in pray where as the first
playthrough where I didn't use any size
hours I felt very secure because I had a
lot of engineering skill and whatever I
would find a turret I would in I would
put it in place I would upgrade it you
know I'd put it in the right position
I'd hear it in the background killing
typhoons the aliens as they came in and
so I was in this reactor room behind
this shielded glass rebooting the
reactor which creates this huge storm of
energy outside the room but I had like
four turrets set up and so anytime
anything would come in and just get
mowed down I felt very powerful but as I
rebooted the reactor to techno pads come
into the area responding to the
disturbance and they just have these
systemic rules where if they get near
some of the operators the the little
robotic floaty things or the turrets
they dominate them that's their nature
as a they're connected to machines and
so the to techno paths flew into the
area they flew by my turrets they sucked
up all four of the turrets so the to
techno paths are now flying around with
these turrets serving them in orbit
around them firing at me and I like
that's a situation I created through my
agency through my play of the game just
a rules interaction and it was in it
worked against me right but I still
loved it because it was like oh my god
that makes sense
I get why this happened but holy [ __ ]
now I have to deal with these four these
two techno paths with four turrets you
know and it's it's the kind of gameplay
that I think we love you know where you
do something in the world reacts in an
interesting way it's not just going to
the next room getting the key opening
the door killing the monster going to
the next room it's it's very creatively
flexible yeah it's fascinating because I
like whether it's Dishonored
- or prey as developers you have to
create these worlds where that's
possible even if you don't intend for
that exact thing to happen yeah we never
conceive of half the things that happen
right um and I am kind of like curious
you know you prey and dishonor two or
very different games right I mean
there's still in the same kind of
sub-genre few are different yeah right
but still just one or two is more like
stealth focused also kind of like a
discreet missions whereas praise this
yeah kind of singular open-world if you
want to call it that yeah on the Telus 1
Space Station um what is it like seeing
Arcana Austin which is separate from
your studio in Lyon where you work on
just under - what's it like seeing them
do such a kind of a new thing that I
know you said
raphaël colantonio I've been wanting to
do that for a long time yeah it's a
total pleasure because very few Studios
specialize in the kind of games that we
make and so RAF and those guys making
prey basically meant that the kind of
game that I love just emerged for me to
play at some point because I was head
down on dishonour - with the team in
Lyon who worked very hard many of them
worked on Dishonored one but they
exclusively did Dishonored 2 with me I
was living in France and now they've
done I moved back halfway through the
death of the outsider and I've been
working with them remotely so they are
also responsible for a death of the
outsider so we were head down on that
and we just only play pray once in a
while to give them a little feedback but
then by the time I moved back to Austin
and they were they needed feedback
around alpha-beta near the end of the
project it was just a sure pleasure you
know to like be able to jump in and play
this kind of game that I loved so much
that just seeming nearly fell out of the
sky to me you know so it was really
great yeah you said you know you there's
room for all different kinds of games in
the industry but do you see this kind of
immersive sim game becoming bigger from
here on out with prey and designer - and
like I said these other properties are
kind of using this kind of gameplay um
what I see is that pieces of things that
work get absorbed into other things
right and so many things that the the
original pioneers of this type of game
whether you're talking about the one
square to time kind of games that came
out of the late 80s like Dungeon Master
or games like that or you're talking
about looking-glass
made underworld and thief and system
shock very important early pioneers of
this kind of you are there
first-person systems based the world is
plausible it acts and reacts the way you
would expect it to according to
expectation I just see all the pieces of
those games have been largely absorbed
even into games that are more abstract
in in nature the same way RPGs used to
be this thing that we're like very
esoteric and now play Call of Duty and
it has all these RPG fans in it you know
so I think it's more like that that
people have cherry-picked parts of it
and it's spread you know yeah you see
some EE a sports games are actually yeah
doing RPG stuff now like NBA live and
everything outside of that uh Madden is
doing that now it's weird to see it kind
of invade all these other genres yeah
but I am I it's it's fascinating to see
how like to go back to deftly outsider I
was talking to Jake Solomon before this
um do you ever feel like you're getting
burnt down dishonored like I know you I
know you love it cuz you've worked on it
but like is there ever this like seeing
our chaos and make prey is there do you
have this kind of itch to do something
different yeah I mean I've worked on
Dishonored games for eight years now
like from the time that raff and I
started Dishonored one in Austin was
co-developed between Leonin and Austin
um through Dishonored one knife of
dunwall brigmore witches Dishonored 2
with Emily and Corvo and now with Billy
lurk and death of the outsider and doubt
that has that has been 8 years and so I
definitely am feeling that called to uh
you know what else is out there what
what should I be exploring right now you
know but that said we love our fans we
love our players and it's been an
amazing ride it does feel like death of
the outsider is the end of a kind of an
arc not the end of Dishonored but the
end of an arc the event around the
assassination of jessamine called one
and the Corvo Emily Dowd Billy's story
it does feel like closure to that you
know so
it which also gives us creative latitude
if we ever talk about new dishonored
stuff I don't know yeah I do kinda wanna
get your take on the rest of the
comfortables you guys have any other
deathly outside of questions that seems
to be well covered yeah yeah that much
here okay I was curious about it what
you thought of what you've seen here um
I haven't seen much actually I went to
the Bethesda showcase so I believe it or
not we don't see some of that stuff so I
had never seen the Wolfenstein trailer
which blew me away I had never seen the
evil within with the amazing cover of
the Duran Duran song ordinary world yep
way back but I was blown away bad stuff
it's very cool I've been part of a
publisher off and on through my 23-year
career but I have to say this is the
first time you just look around at all
the other studios and you're just like
intimidated humbled amazed that the
things your your peers are working on
whether it's the Fallout games or the
elder scrolls bringing more wins to the
MMO the guys that machine game work
working out machine games working on
Wolfenstein it's all cool and we got
lots of feedback from them on death of
the outsider and Billy lurk as a
character but that said also walking
around I'm aware of what's here or what
people are talking about and I you
mentioned Jake Solomon like I'm super
excited about the new x-column stuff I
hope that's really good I want to play
that there's new content coming for
horizon zero dawn I think so excited
about that Tacoma is something I'm
watching because I love gone home and
the guys that worked on that so I mean
it's overwhelming because especially
when you like you guys you're working
well your view is probably more
transversal of everything mind is much
more head down talking about Billy lurk
and doubt and yeah the outsider so a lot
of it for me is watching the videos
later when I go back to the hotel room
and I'm just wiped out and exhausted I'm
in a bathrobe and I'm watching that's my
evening by the way but yeah that sounds
like that's not right um what about the
Xbox one ex I guess that's like a thing
I just I've kind of been asking anytime
I get the chance to chat with a
developer this week I'm asking what they
kind of think of this new console
if you want to call it that's moving
toward more like the PC side of things
from your perspective as developer does
that change how you think about
development at all you know I have a
developer's view of that in that more
power is always better yeah but at the
same time it's also requires more
support and backwards support and all
that it's a little more complicated but
I think in general we'll see we'll see
how the players respond to it but I'm
generally very optimistic about it yeah
like all the things that are being
brought to it you know I know I'll get
one I'm excited you know I have a ps4 at
home also and I have a high end PC you
know so it's it's all good and I haven't
bought a switch yet but I want to buy a
switch you know so but I'm probably
anomalous in that I don't I don't feel
compelled to pick one and and go with it
you know I'm always straddling two or
three last time for me it was probably
PC iPhone and xbox360 and this time I've
spent a lot of time on my ps4 my PC yeah
I've actually been disappointed with the
mobile games lately like it feels like
we went through a period of time where
mobile games are really exciting yeah
and nothing's really caught my attention
lately I don't know maybe maybe that'll
change soon but yeah you mentioned like
hitman go and like was it Lara off mark
rothko was great too but since then
there hasn't been yeah you're right now
I think about there hasn't really been
like a discoverability is such a
challenge on mobile yeah there you go
I mean like it's great that everybody
more and more people can make games
tools are more freeform everything's out
there you can just put it up or whatever
but it doesn't help anybody if it's just
instantly lost in a massive sea of
uncured contents or whatever you know so
I'm glad that's not my problem to solve
yeah that sounds like a very hard
problem but yeah I don't want to ask
while we're actually it's kind of like
we're on a stream right now and Jake
Saunders saying whenever he's playing a
game he almost always has a stream up
and he's look at his phone and
everything and then with game the kind
of games you make there's a reward
experimentation and you find out things
that you could do like you mentioned the
chicken and breath of a wild of chucko
chucko where they're called yeah I like
finding things like that that you didn't
know could happen just like it's funny
that you know the kind of games you make
seem almost tailor-made
for like these YouTube videos that come
out or like the streamer to find
something crazy excited like does that
affect how you see your games in the
aftermath like I know I was talking to
you before like what it's like to see
people playing Dishonored on YouTube
like the next day and like doing things
that you didn't even consider yeah I
mean that phenomenon is really fantastic
and I've told the story before about how
at the end of dishonored one long before
death of the outsider and the Wilier
conclusion and all that just we had just
finished Dishonored 1 and we were
working on a knife of dunwall or
something I think or a patch actually
was earlier than that we ran a patch or
something and riptides is one of those
early streamers that we watched Riptide
Bo W I don't remember what his exact
handle is but he was playing the very
end of the game and you know he played
the entire game and every day we'd walk
through the the break area and like stop
at the monitor and look oh he's he's
thirty third of the way through the game
always half of the way through the game
and by the time you get to the final
mission the end the whole team was
gathered in this break room around this
monitor watching talking and I'll never
forget he like Admiral Havelock had
Emily it was like the high chaos ending
or whatever and was threatening to drop
her off the tower and he was like I in
my memory it's probably wrong but in my
memory was eating or something and he
was like oh yeah sure you're gonna drop
the little girl off the tower video game
and then she goes and falls her doom you
know and he was just like what and so we
all had this amazing reaction to
watching somebody else work their way
through the gameplay and through the
story and stuff it's very gratifying in
a way that I wouldn't have anticipated
and what a way to get feedback right
like most honest feedback possible yeah
yeah exactly and not only what they're
saying but what people in the comments
are saying is that do you take that too
into account when you go into something
like death of the outsider yeah I mean
not not too much because uh for at least
this arc of Dishonored games we pretty
much have a vision for them we know that
people play them you know we have
several people who play dishonored in
the most stealthy way possible and they
comment as they're playing and they try
all the little clever things and other
dishonored fans are watching them and
something goes wrong and it all goes
crazy violent or whatever we anticipate
that for the the Billy lerk death of the
outsider chapter as well but as yet we
haven't really like moved the game to
that to something that's more supportive
of that model you know we've we've been
pretty focused on this is the kind of
game we make it's all about being a
badass supernatural assassin jumping
rooftop to rooftop killing off corrupt
aristocrats sneaking past guards trying
to be careful but then when things go
wrong going super violent you know
yeah it's that's pretty much like what
our players love about the Dishonored
games that in the rich world you know
the work we do layers and layers of
environmental storytelling in the world
is a very plausible complete world even
though it's a fantasy world so yeah so I
do hope death of the outsider is a an
entry point for some people who haven't
played and I also hope that the people
who have been with us this eight-year
ride liked it as well they liked the
conclusion that we come to yeah to be
kind of a geek quick about like the
history of this kind of game you know
like you can look at Dishonored as an
homage to theif almost and then you can
look at praise and omage the system
shock and then even if you want to go
back before you at arcane you know when
they open with ArcSight alice is kind of
an homage to all Ultima Underworld yeah
yeah do you see anything else from the
past you'd like to see come back whether
it's from your from someone else well
I'm really excited about the new Metro
game yeah and so you know there's always
been like a vibe there a tone that I've
that I found appealing because it's from
a culture outside my own or whatever
right stalker originally was like kind
of magical for some of us so yeah I mean
it was also Terranova a game nobody
remembers that it was like based on the
Wing Commander structure of play but you
played a you know a Power Suit power
armor character in a sci-fi setting and
some of the mission design behind that
was really really amazing for its time
awesome
uh yeah so we're just gonna close it out
and go back up to our stage momentarily
but last question I guess like $30 death
the outsider when can we play it
$29.99 actually oh sorry
hahaha bet you're professional I'm tired
it's available death of the outsider
starring Billy lurk
stand-alone is available September 15th
okay cool well Harvey thanks so much for
coming on stage we closed it out sooner
not quickly I've meant to do this
earlier in the show but if you watch the
lobby you know we do giveaways
this one's actually kind of huge if you
follow a gamespot on twitter you can go
we have a link on the site doing LG and
Newegg
are teaming up to it's like an entire
gaming prize pack it's a 34 inch ultra
wide HD curved LED gaming monitor as
well as mechanical gaming keyboard
stereo gaming headset gaming mice $50
Newegg gift card we're gonna choose one
winner tonight and another one tomorrow
night so you can go to GameSpot if you
don't follow us on Twitter do that and
then you can go check that out but yeah
we're gonna go back up the state
upstairs but Harvey thank you so much
for joining thank you guys have a good
rest of the show and thanks for talking
about death The Outsider we're always
yeah and everybody thank you so much for
joining here we really appreciate it we
appreciate seeing some familiar face
into streaming everything we're gonna
throw it back upstairs to the stage for
another demo throughout the day but stay
tuned a game spot see you there